- [Host] There's a reason the carpet
at this New York City Premiere is blue.
The studio behind this new series
isn't Universal or Paramount
Pictures, it's Walmart.
- Don't look at me like, like that.
♪ It's all right 'cause
you're all I need ♪
- [Host] Walmart says, this
isn't a typical romcom,
it's romcommerce.
- Just decided this is so me.
- And it's called "Add to Heart."
Viewers can buy those items
and over 330 others
directly from Walmart while
watching the series on
TikTok, Roku and YouTube.
- This is a big bet for us.
- [Host] Here's why
Walmart and other companies
are investing in so-called
shoppable content
even though the trend has
yet to take off in the US.
The series follows the
typical holiday romcom plot.
City girl returns to her hometown
and bumps into an old flame.
- Jess.
- Javi?
- There's a little bit of
cheesiness within a romantic
comedy of course, but there's
nothing cheesy in the selling
and it feels very seamless
and natural in how it comes together.
- [Host] On TikTok, each
three minute episode runs
as a paid in-feed ad featuring
10 shoppable product tiles.
Roku users see an ad on their
home screen, which takes them
to the series playlist while watching,
they can shop for products by pressing,
okay on their Roku remote.
- Babe, can I come out now?
- This allows users to
text themselves a link
to shop on their phone, on
YouTube, users can find a link
to all the products in
the description box.
- You like this unpacking
for my Miami trip?
- [Host] Almost everything
in the 23-part series
from the outfits
to the decor is from Walmart.
- Products were chosen from
things that are giftable, things
that we think are really
on trend for the season.
- If they wanted to see the jacket
and then also the outfit under it.
It might be like we come into the scene
with the jacket and then we take it off.
It's 10 degrees outside.
- What did you say?
- There's a shot, it's in the trailer
with like walking up to the door.
That was an example of
a scene where we had
to really get it right, like
the placement of the shoes had
to be very exact.
- Merry Christmas babe.
- [Host] To measure consumer engagement,
Walmart looks at three things.
One, are people adding
the item to their cart?
- Who proposes after six months?
Does he even know your middle name?
- [Host] Two, are they buying it
and three, if they're not buying it,
do they come back to it later?
- If the scoop boots was
something that you added
to your cart but then
abandoned, but then went
and bought them in
store later, we consider
that inspiration moment happening from the
content that they first saw there.
- [Host] "Add to Heart"
is the newest iteration of
what Walmart calls its
social commerce strategy.
The company has also
partnered with NBC/Universal
to create a shoppable
experience in season eight
of Bravo's Reality Show
"Below Deck Mediterranean"
on Peacock.
- What do you mean I'm not on top?
- Well, you're obviously not.
- [Host] During ad breaks,
viewers get served an ad
for a Walmart product similar
to the one they just saw in the show,
and they can buy it using
the QR code on screen.
- Let's get Merry and Bright.
- [Host] Other companies
like Home Depot have
also dabbled in this space.
- Let's get to decorating.
- [Host] It created a
shoppable series called
"Merry and Bright" where viewers
can buy items using integrated
QR codes, and a number
of companies have been using
TikTok's video shopping ads,
which launched last year.
- You have every player in
the ecosystem thinking we have
to be able to unlock
more shopping activity.
- [Host] Christopher Vollmer
is a managing director at MediaLink,
a media and marketing consulting firm.
Walmart is a MediaLink client.
Vollmer, however, does not
personally advise Walmart.
- You've got media
companies that are trying
to unlock new sources of
revenue and you've got brands
and retailers that are trying to be
where all the attention is,
which is social media
platforms and streaming.
- [Host] Vollmer says
Apple's privacy change
in 2021 that restricted
how users are tracked, also
triggered many companies
to move away from cookie-based ads.
- What they're trying to do
now is build up much more
of a first party data
relationship with consumers
and actually push them more
and more to their own environments
where they can enact a transaction
and build more of a
long-term relationship.
- [Host] Shoppable content
is popular in China,
but it's still in its
early days in the US.
- It has been a slower ramp in the US
but it is definitely ramping.
It's taken off a little bit more
with younger generations first,
and I think we're just developing
the norms in the routines
and the behavior here in the US right now.
- The content has to be great.
It can be a fantastic user experience,
but if it's not embedded in a story
that users find a very
compelling, very interesting,
it's not gonna be something
that they come back to.
- Javi, I have something to tell you.
- [Host] Walmart didn't share any
data about its social commerce efforts.
- Do not get me started
about the color of this bag.
- [Host] But White says
there's been more traffic
to the Walmart site and increased sales.
- I think we will pick up a
lot of learnings along the way
that will continue to inform
and help us progress down
this shoppable journey.
- Mr. Bogle, is it possible
to add a stop at Walmart on the way?
- Absolutely.
(upbeat music)